you did this one thing that I want to
talk about where you ran around with Jon
Hamm this is a season premiere this was
the season premiere this season ability
on the street a few years ago on the
show we played a game with Paul Rudd
called would you have sex with Paul Rudd
and ran around Manhattan asked me people
everyone said yes yeah you know man
woman everyone right right so this time
we up the ante and we did would you have
a threesome with me and Jon Hamm right
that's an interesting one yes because
this time I said it's not you know if
the question is not will you have sex
with Jon Hamm obviously you would but I
am part of the package yeah right it's a
package deal you have to accept me and
not everyone was that excited about that
right I think we have a clip from that
should we show it let's do it yeah all
right let's take a look at this clip
miss for a dollar would you have a
threesome with me and Jon Hamm me and
Jon Hamm course not Oh
[Applause]
who can blame her
Holi in New York I love that such an
honest reaction
you